a bison is so powerful like
an animal
a very large animal with very massive features
finally they are very small compared to the
power that nature can have
when the few meters in front of us
for a long time blown when they look at us
it is an intensity  incredible it
still sends shivers
[Music]
with a friend around the age of 10-11 years old he
built a cabin in a tree quite
simply and we observed in
front of this cabin rabbits we were
observed with with  binoculars me I
borrowed my father's and the passion
for nature I really thought came
like that my first
photos were very documentary photos so I
tried to put more spas
centers months the animal to have more  of
breathing in the images to have
something more built
I tried to give myself
more importance to the environment to the play
of light than the animal itself you prefer to
take a photo of a small house everything
stupidly in a superb and
the environment like taking a
very very rare bird in finally light
or in an environment which would not be very
very beautiful
[Music]
there are times when we take photos
where the atmosphere where the light is  beautiful
or the moment we are so calm
that we just need to ask ourselves to be
in tune with our environment
[Music] that
was my name of serenity or in fact
we just wait without necessarily seeing the
time pass
it is  completely disconnected we
pay attention to nothing more
than nature and what surrounds us and that
's cool
[Music]
in europe for almost two hundred years
there are no more wild bison currently
in the money  to the wwf which in the process of
reintroducing like bison in the wild
since this project chouchan impatient
to go see them because now
in our society it is so
complicated to see protecting nature
the impression that people finally
labro  there  nature is completely
apart from their life when it forms a
whole and I find it really important
this kind of initiative project for
our future for us quite simply
[Music]
not
a karpatz and a region of
romania that I  never seen my city
I really wanted to go there to
fill in this species of tuna
mountains as far as the eye can see
filled with old forests and it's a
bit of a myth actually
[Music]
when I arrive at a place for the
first time so we don't really know
where to start
the first days when we are going to
travel it always seems very very
long to us we say to ourselves marc chappuis
kilometers and kilometers
we can say to ourselves such that at the next
bend we will see the bison there  will be right
there we may not and who will
only be 5 km away so still have to
walk a lot
so it's a bit of a game between cat
and mouse where we try to find him a little bit
and that's maybe  be one of one
can avoid us
think the p  patience is one of the
main things to have 100 patients
it's not possible to see animals
if after half an hour an hour you're
fed up and you want to get out of there was
it's just not possible you
usually have to  several hours to
actually be forgotten by nature it
takes a lot of time sometimes
maybe a week for films in one
day when we will be able to take pictures
because we will be exactly
where the animal is going to come out
oh
in vain
or
oh
when I'm traveling and it's been
a week or a week and a half since
I took no photos I
wonder why why I
'm here wouldn't it be better at
home surrounded by my family  going to see
my friends than being cold in my
afur when the difficulties pile up
it's not going to be a france was going to be an
additional motivation
precisely because perhaps the day just
after everything will change and nature
is so  unpredictable o  n can
spend two weeks three weeks without
seeing anything and then boom the day comes when
business 2000 photos we are waiting for
the animal to arrive a convoy the animal in
our water sight photo work
his skin so much emotion c  is
such an intense moment
it's a moment that will last perhaps
30 seconds a minute sometimes 5/5 great
maximum over almost a day
of waiting
once this click effect all the
difficulties evaporate we finally have this
micro moments of life we wanted I was
finally privileged because I was
all alone to have this scene there and t
e final click is what closes it al
that's great [Musi
] ban [
usi
] [Musi
]
[Music]
en